[BEEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Google
Container Registry
is a private container
image registry
that runs on Google Cloud
Platform's reliable, fast,
and secure infrastructure.
You can access
Container Registry
through secure HTTPS
end points, which
allow you to push,
pull, and manage images
from any system, VM instance,
or your own hardware.
Additionally, you can use
the Docker Credential Helper
command line tool to configure
Docker to authenticate directly
with Container Registry.
While Docker provides
a central registry
for storing public images,
you might not want your images
to be accessible to the world.
To control access
to your images,
you must store them
in a private registry.
This hands-on lab
demonstrates how
to build a Docker image
containing a basic Python web
app and push it to Google
Container Registry.
This lab is also
part of a series
of labs called Qwik Starts.
These labs are
designed to give you
a little taste of the many
features available with Google
Cloud.
Search for Qwik Starts
in the lab catalog
to find the next lab
that you'd like to take.
Next up on our quest
is Deployment Manager--
Qwik Start.